the world is about to plug back into the
matrix but will Laurence Fishburne be on
the other side this time around Warner
Brothers dropped a bombshell on August
20th when it announced that filmmaker
lana wachowski one half of the
directorial duo behind the original
Matrix trilogy is set to write and
direct the long-awaited fourth Matrix
film Keanu Reeves will reprise his role
as neo and his co-star carrie-anne moss
is confirmed to step back into her role
as Nebuchadnezzar crew member and Neos
love interest Trinity that news break
came as a welcome surprise and it seemed
that the matrix four would be one big
matrix family reunion the only problem
there was no mention of Laurence
Fishburne's involvement in FL Fishburne
starred opposite Reeves and moss and all
three Matrix movies playing Morpheus the
Nebuchadnezzar captain who recruited neo
to aid in the fight to break humanity
free from the virtual reality known as
the matrix considering Morpheus neo and
Trinity are the core trio of the Matrix
franchise and given that Reeves and moss
are locked in for the matrix for you'd
assume that Fishburne would also come
back for the upcoming film however that
might not end up happening according to
varieties Justin Kroll Fishburne may not
return because the film might not
include his character and his current
age the matrix for will reportedly
feature a younger version of Morpheus
and Warner Brothers is said to be on the
hunt for the perfect person for the game
shortly after the initial news broke
troll wrote on Twitter if you've asked
yourself where's Morpheus sources have
told me this may point to where and when
the film is set as I've heard execs are
looking at a variety of young actors to
possibly play young Morpheus stay tuned
on that front
now just because Warner Brothers is
apparently in an active search for the
right person to portray a fresh-faced
version of everyone's favorite freedom
fighter doesn't completely rule out the
possibility that Fishburne will appear
in the matrix for someone new to the
Matrix franchise might step up and
portray young Morpheus with Fishburne
still appearing as the regular aged
version of himself anything can happen
in the matrix
perhaps Warner Brothers knows exactly
what it's doing here and is purposefully
holding out on announcing Fishburne's
inclusion to build additional buzz
around the new matrix the studio already
hit us with huge news when it confirmed
that the project was happening maybe
Warner Brothers brass doesn't want to
give franchise fans everything all at
once and is holding on to the juicy
tidbit that is Fishburne's potential
involvement until a later date they are
guarding all the doors they are holding
all the keys which means that sooner or
later someone is going
to have to fight them on that notes
there's also the chance that Warner
Brothers is still negotiating with
Fishburne about returning his Morpheus
it isn't every day that an actor learns
that the franchise they last appeared in
16 years ago is getting another
installment and Fishburne could very
well be conflicted about the idea of
being a part of the new movie he has
remained incredibly busy in the time
since the Matrix Revolutions debuted in
2003 appearing in films like Mission
Impossible three days of wrath predators
Man of Steel Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice ant-man in the wasp and two of
the John wick films Fishburne has also
found success on the small screen in his
post matrix life playing dr. Raymond
Langston on a handful of CSI series Jack
Crawford on Hannibal and Earl pops
Johnson on blackish and grown ish
clearly the guy has been doing pretty
well for himself over the years this
considered it's plausible that Fishburne
is completely satisfied with his
professional life and may not be
interested in reprise in his matrix role
that he hung up so many years ago
it's a mystery for now whether Fishburne
will be involved in the matrix for but
for our parts were holding out hope that
we'll get to hear him say a few iconic
lines at least one more time free
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]